[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a truly
remarkable game from the greek team
championship uh it comes as a suggestion
from a user named nick city uh so thank
you for that and it's uh athanasius
master of atlas versus motion nicolo
sorry if i'm pronouncing that wrong i
did not have um all that much practice
with great greek names uh but the game
itself it's simply phenomenal so i hope
you guys enjoy this uh it will well
improve your saturday at least tenfold
uh so let's check it out the white with
the white pieces opens with d4 we have
knight to f6
c4 uh we have e6 and g3 sorry about that
uh white goes for the catalan opening
preparing to tinker to his light square
bishop uh and here is still the most
common reply is d5 but black strikes in
the center right away with c5 also very
popular just not as popular as d5 yet
maybe uh white advances the pawn to d5
because this is now uh how the chess is
played nowadays you do not
miss up an opportunity to grab more
space uh e cartridge on d5c captures and
now d6 uh and we have knight to c3 uh
continuing development g6 now preparing
to vinca to the dark square bishop and
bishop to g2 we have bishop to g7 and
knight to f3 and we've basically
transposed into the
benoni defense uh and here black just
castle so this is nothing new this has
been played many many times there are
like 4 000 games just in top tier
tournaments with this exact same
position
so we have castles by white as well and
rook to e8 and now the usual uh way
white will play this is to go knight to
d2 uh it's very standard you want to
bring this knight to c4 put pressure on
the d6 pawn play bishop f4 put more
pressure on the spawn at and black will
at some point probably will even have to
defend it with bishop to f8 so there are
many many lines here uh of course you
guys know all of that and also just the
immediate bishop to f4
uh putting pressure on the pawn right
away but here we have rook to e1 it's a
very rare move and it's one that as
you'll see white prepared very very
nicely so here a6 black of course wants
to go for the usual b5 white stops this
plays a4 now controls b5 and knight b to
d7 and now bishop to f4 attacking the
pawn here and now knight to h5 going
after the bishop and sing you are more
than welcome to grab my d6 pawn but this
is uh still all very known theory um if
bishop captures on e6 we can play queen
b6 attack the bishop ended the pawn here
and now it's very hard to
get out of this if you just move the
bishop we're going to capture it mess up
your pawn structure here in front of
your king and still capture on b2 so
that's pretty bad we're gonna have to go
into something like g4 queen captures
pawn captures and then after g
characters we're gonna have a very very
sharp game with both kings uh uh wide
open like this uh but in the game we
have bishop to g5 another known idea
attacking the queen on the 8th queen to
c7 sidestepping this attack and now
white grabs more space with e4
we've broke the b8 trying to go for that
b5 move and now you could go for
something like a5 it's
um
it's a standard idea in such positions
where if black plays b5 you want to
capture a capture some b6 alpha
and then leave black with a
weak
a6 pawn but in the game
we have g4 challenging this knight and
now what can black play well you have to
bring the knight back there's really
nothing else knight to f6 and then now
comes h3 and this h3 is a new move in
the game
the position has been reached before for
example in the women's world team
championship between tanjong and tatev
abrahamian where the immediate e5 was
played however i think white was a very
aware of this game and he decided to not
go for this because in that game d
captures an e5 was played but if black
wants black could go for the sharpest
knight captures on g4 and then for
example e6 knight to f8 or rather knight
d to f6 and black uh black is holding
this doesn't seem to be having all that
much problems so this is why i think
white decided to avoid the immediate e5
and play h3 first defending the g4 pawn
and next he's gonna play e5 so this is a
new move even though i i've i took the
game from the leeches database deletions
database states that b5 from black is
actually a new move but i i only use a
free database so maybe this
game that had this particular move was
not in my free database so it's possible
i'm still going to call the h3 uh the
completely new game but like i said it's
possible that it's b5 so okay a
characters on b5 we have a captures on
b5 and only now e5 so the difference
between that and the game that we
discussed is that now the g64 g6 pawn is
protected so you can play knight
captures on g4 and also we captured once
on b5 so uh some future rook lifting
might be possible so those are some of
the differences so d captures an e5 and
now of course the e5 pawn is defended
three times we remove one of the
defenders we play d6 challenge the queen
queen to b6 and now we play bishop
captures on f6 this is the
tricky move uh because now if you
capture with the knight uh then you no
longer defend the pawn then we can uh
take the pawn as well so bishop captures
on f6 was played and now g5 also a very
important move everything white played
here is placed to such perfection that
um
you know it's uh just just enjoyable to
just watch so bishop back the g7 and now
knight the d5 attacking the queen you
have a very nice outpost for the knight
on e7 and also potential in some lines
even on f6 so queen to d8 and now you
don't go for knight to e7 right away
because if 97 check black will happily
give up the rook for for the knight and
this incredibly strong pawn so first
white played rook to a7 so utilizing
both of the differences from the game
that we've discussed that the rook is
now allowed to do to go for this
beautiful rook lift putting pressure on
the entire seventh rank so here uh black
should play something like rook to b7
and then it's unclear what white had in
mind here maybe maybe capturing maybe
just rook 8 and then maybe rook b8 and
then we see a repetition who knows
i'm sure of course he had something in
mind because these are two very strong
grandmasters but in the game bishop to
b7 was played and this allows white to
continue his happy attack so knight the
e7 with check but now with the
difference that if you capture the uh
this now and try to give up the exchange
like this now knight to h2 is super
annoying attacking the bishop twice and
also if the bishop moves there is a
double attack on this knight so you're
you could even play queen g5 pin the
bishop here
but we simply capture on b7 and after
rook captures h4 and the queen can no
longer keep pinning the bishop once the
queen moves we're just going to pick up
the rook on b7 so white would be well
close to winning here if not winning but
okay after knight to e7 check king to f8
uh and now comes knight the h4 another
brilliant move this is uh you know
setting up like like it was a tall game
and now the question is can you capture
on g2 now yes you could if you capture
on g2 we're going to capture back and
now how do you find a move here for
black it's very unclear yeah is there
even a good move here for black for
example if you try to trade works we're
just going to play rook to c7 and what
can you play knight to the b6 we're
going to play knight to c6 challenge the
queen and now again no good moves for
the black queen if queen g5 we're gonna
play d7 and this is again now just
winning for white it's uh
too overwhelming a position to hold for
black so after this knight h4 move black
played queen to b6 right away it's uh
the absolute best reply he goes after
the rook here but now white has this
beautiful rook captures on b7 so of
course you can't capture back with the
queen you have to capture with the
bishop and now we have queen to d5 with
a double attack on the rook here so what
do you play here well this is the
crucial position and black should have
played something like rook e to b8 and
still black's position would be very
difficult here white is just mounting a
beautiful attack but black played rook
to a7 here and this is what makes our
move or rather a series of moves
possible
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning idea for white
it's actually a forced checkmate in four
so while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on figuring out
what the position is all about and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course queen captures on
f7 with check we start off with a queen
sacrifice even though
you don't have to you could actually
start by capturing uh the g6 pawn for
example knight captures on g6 h captures
on g6 and then the same idea applies
queen captures and f7 king captures
bishop d5 check king to f8 and now
knight the g6 will be checkmate as
everything is nicely covered here and
you cannot block anything of course the
uh check with the knight cannot be
blocked it can just be avoided uh so now
instead after rook day seven queen
captures on f7 was played right away and
this is a a good uh thing to remember if
you can deliver mate in four with uh
a queen sacra if you start with a queen
sacrifice it's much better to do it than
you know start with something else and
then sacrifice the queen it's just you
know much flashier and more people will
see it and remember it uh so here queen
captures an f7 it's also a fine position
for any book on tactics or you know
if they still make those um you know
just uh uh c see the power of the two
knights in this knight stage for setting
this up is just amazing so there's only
one reply king captures on f7 and now
the same idea bishop d5 check king to f8
and now knight e captures on g6 with
check black's only movies to capture
back and after captures knight to g6
delivers checkmate incredible incredible
stuff here
uh i have to you know draw some arrows
and make some uh colors red to use for
the thumbnail uh but yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it once again
uh thank you a lot and very much nikti
for suggesting such a wonderful game uh
and also it was the perfect moment to
show it as we have a rest day in the us
chess championship today i would like to
thank tom daralo nicolas taxidis um
david kimura john cousins and prashant
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it as usual
you can check to all my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the usgs championship checking up on
your wonderful suggestions hopefully as
nice as this one and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your saturday